um
welcome everyone and uh i hope already
the tiny conversation was maybe a good
start
um thank you all so much for joining
this
evening session of talks at uh padera
amsterdam or the party
amsterdam festival for this year and
we're pleased to announce that uh our
first speaker for tonight
is uh jim darling co-founder ceo of
logical clocks and he's
he's here to tell us about hotbox.ai
which is in or also has an open source
feature store for machine learning
please jim the floor is all yours thanks
all right so we're european and this is
open source it's the open source session
and hopsworks is an open source platform
and they're going to talk
in particular about the featured store
aspect of it so it's a modular platform
for
data science and it contains a feature
store but we're going to talk
mostly about that and then this
hopservers.ai
part that's the new sas version of our
platform
and that's available currently on aws i
think it's the only
full stack ai sas platform from europe
currently um it's also a data platform
but
we might have time for a little demo at
the end so
let's kick off yeah who are we we're
based in stockholm primarily
um we have one person in the netherlands
and we have a couple of other offices
so i'm going to start by by giving you a
data engineering perspective and i i
would say
i fall more into the data engineering
studies even though i've
taught course in deep learning um
data engineers look at feature and
engineering and
and the work that data scientists do to
train models and they don't i don't
think they really understand the gap
right
so they have their data in databases
they have varchars they have files
they have objects and object stores and
they have the sql types
and the language they speak is the
language of back-end
data platforms and the language data
scientists speak is the language of
numpy numerical features categorical
features um and there is a gap between
them
so what data engineers often don't
understand they think well i have my
data in my operational database and on
the left you can see we have
a database with a lot of hotel bookings
in it the bookings just have a start
date and end date and then the room
number
but the data scientists know that well i
need to maybe compute or
transform that raw data in features so
maybe i want to compute a feature like
the load factor over room
and that feature load factor it could be
used in many different models so it's
not going to be
used in just one to predict whether room
could be free or
be occupied in a given period of time it
might be also used to predict revenue at
the hotel
over a period of time so feature
engineering this process of getting your
back-end data
and making it available for models is
about transforming data
and sometimes we need to do it at scale
and sometimes there are edge cases that
data engineers again don't understand
you might have
some numerical features here i'm just
going to pull up a pen actually here
so i can actually highlight things so
you can see we have an array of features
here and it's a nice
little um close it so
it's it looks fine and clean and maybe a
data scientist will look at it and say
well hang on we have
oh that's quite big we have um like a
little bit smaller
so that size small okay so um they look
at that and so
this isn't isn't ideal we might have
some numerical instability here so i'm
going to normalize
uh those particular uh features so you
might decide to do that
often what we'll see in the data
engineering world is we might want to do
it
so that we'll scale we have a large
volume of data and here we have a little
code snippet doing that in pi spark
and there's framework support in
pinespark for doing future engineering
at scale
so we have challenges of doing future
engineering and then we have how to do
it at scale
so what we have introduced is called a
feature store and the feature store
is this api between data engineering and
data science
it's a place where the data engineers
can cache or materialize
these features so the values of the
features will be available there
and the data scientists can come along
and say well i like those features maybe
you have the load example from
our hotel room or maybe in this case we
have the titanic example so we have
the titanic uh passenger list here and
we want to
and that tells us whether passengers
survived or not and we have features
like the sex of the passengers and
whether they're in first class or second
class
and we can imagine that somebody has
done some research and found out the
bank account balances of the people in
the titanic and that data comes in from
a different source a different platform
but we put it in the same feature store
so the idea behind the feature store is
that data scientists can come along
and just take features and reuse them in
different models
so what they'll do is they'll take a
bunch of features in this case the data
scientist might say i'll add that bank
account balance to the titanic
passenger list data and now a new
uh data set with this bank account
balance is a new feature
which will hopefully help me predict a
little bit better if a passenger
survived or not because i have a
hypothesis that
if they a lot of money they bribe to get
on the titanic
now this looks a little bit intimidating
if you're a data scientist we have join
keys and we have arrows pointing
everywhere
and here there i'll show a little code
snippet in a little bit to show you it's
a lot simpler than that
and but what data scientists want to do
is they want the flexibility to say okay
i'm joining these features together
but i want the output the data i'd like
either maybe
i just want the numpy array
maybe as a file or maybe i just want a
pandas data frame which i can get
directly in my
in my application and work directly from
there but often when you've large
volunteer data you might want to
train on deep learning with tf record or
you might want to use csv for whatever
reason or even a scalable
file format like petastorm then you also
need to decide where am i going to store
this data
so you might decide to store it in s3 if
you're working in amazon
uh we have our own file system there's
uh gcs and there's hadoop there's plenty
of different file systems to store your
data in
so um yeah let me have a look there was
a little bit of flashing no questions
yet you can just pop in a question in
the q a and i'll have a look at them if
there's anything appears there
okay so i haven't said much about what
the features are that we work within
as what i'll try and do here is is give
a quick taxonomy of the types of
features you have
so you have some features that arrive
with with low latency so they're being
updated all the time
or maybe it's data that arrives that we
don't have enough time for that data
to push into the store and pull it out
in our model itself so if for example we
have a
data arriving on a web page and a user
has to
enter that data we need to transform
that data into features
and then make a prediction and we've
only two seconds to do that so in that
case we typically won't materialize that
feature to the feature store
we'll just push it straight through but
for other cases where we have
data for example that um arrives every
few seconds or
every 30 seconds or every hour every day
but
in this case we can have a pipeline so
we can have different pipelines a
streaming application pipeline
we could have a pandas application
pipeline or a spark application pipeline
and they'll push that data and depending
on the type of data so if it's click
data it might come very frequently
cdc data from it from a database an
operational database
it might come quite frequently but then
things like web logs don't get updated
that often
so these types of features will end up
in the feature store and then what we'll
have
is we'll have our online application
here which will be able to say hey i
only have 10 features available
through real-time transformations but i
need another hundred features to train
to to make predictions
so please give me those hundred
prediction those hundred features and
give them to me at low latency
and we saw the example already of data
scientists who would like to train
models they'd like to generate
training data batch applications like
spark applications or pi spark
applications they can also
just pull data directly from the feature
store so we have two different
requirements here
one is that we we have this low latency
requirement for for serving features
but we also have the uh requirement to
scale to large volumes of data
so we have one uh customer in sweden the
largest bank spread bank they have 40
terabytes four zero terabytes
of transaction data they talked about at
the last spark summit
and so no database that's out there
right now that we're aware of
has uh this scalability to petabytes and
very low predictable latencies for
features serving so what we're
doing is we end up dividing up our
feature store into a dual database
architecture an
online feature store for caching the
online features that will be accessed by
online applications
and then this scalable sql layer we call
the offline feature store
that will be able to store large volumes
of data
so what we used in our platform to
because we already talked about this
notion of groups of features that are
computed together
and we talked about training data sets
and individual features well we this
feature group abstraction that we
introduce what it's there to do is to
simplify
storing your data to both the online and
offline feature stores so what we
introduce is in fact a data frame api
so the feature engineering pipelines
over here
will push data frames so they can be
pandas data frames they can be
pi spark data frames or just scala spark
data frames
but they get pushed into the feature
store so now the developers of feature
engineering pipelines don't need to
worry about synchronizing data between
an
offline and an online store they just
say i'm going to
update this feature group or i'm going
to create a new feature group and here's
the data frame
containing the data for that feature
group and
we have some cases where we have uh
feature pipelines that don't go directly
to
the feature store but what they can do
for example at one customer we're
using flink to do real-time feature
engineering and but what thing can do is
it can push
the features that it computes in the
background to the offline feature store
so we can still
gain the benefits of it even if the
online features are computed
um in real time and not then they don't
go through the feature store
okay so yeah so we so we we have this uh
general purpose data frame api
that we used to ingest in the feature
store at this point i should mention
that some of you may have read about
um feature stores from uber or from
airbnb
and they have domain-specific languages
that they provide
for doing feature engineering and when
we looked at this we we
did release the first for the open
source feature store at the end of 2018
and but we wanted a general purpose
framework so we didn't want to
specifically
do feature engineering for given domains
which is what they're kind of doing
and and that's where we ended up at the
data frame api
okay so i promised you a little bit of
code so here's a snippet
and here we have creating a feature
group
feature group is here has a name we
actually have a lot more parameters as
you can guess in here so one of them is
online equals true so if you write
online equals true it's also going to
create this feature group in the
both the online and offline by default
offline
okay and what we can see here is that we
have
this uh data frame which is being read
up and i'm not specifying where it's
coming from
you can have derived features which
which read up data from the feature
store
or you can have base features which read
up on
raw data sources the back ends the data
lakes the data warehouses the
operational uh data databases
so our data frame will read the data
from some place you'll do
your feature engineering on it and then
all we do is we call this uh
feature store dot create feature group
with our data frame as a parameter in
the name
there are other um parameters in here
about computing statistics
over your features as they arrive
statistics so
you you want to know descriptive
statistics and you want to know
distributions of individual feature
values
and they get computed automatically you
can turn off computation of them
and we've been using spark to do that
computation but we're
now moving over to a library called dq
and for that
okay so this is where we where we kind
of are we have this feature store we've
looked at the
ingestion of data into the feature store
and now we'll have a quick look at both
online applications how they use it and
then also how we train
uh we generate training data sets for
users
okay so creating train data sets for
users
we are actually using spark as the
compute engine so
what we need to do is we need to take
all of these features and we have this
little code snippet here these are
assuming a flat name space of features
so um in this flat namespace
assuming there's no clashes between uh
feature names across future groups and
we do support scoping
in our latest api and what the
feature store will do is it has a query
planner that will look for the feature
groups associated with these features
it will look for a common um uh look for
the largest overlapping set of primary
key
columns between them and then it will
join them together and we're actually
using spark as the engine to do that
now you can call this from an external
jupiter notebook
you know for example running on kubeflow
or just a normal jupiter notebook or on
stagemaker but what it will do in that
case is it will actually run the spark
job on our cluster
if you have your own spark cluster you
can run it on your own
cluster like databricks or hadoop so
what happens when you call this
futurestor.getfeatures is it's basically
reading up
each of the feature groups as data
frames and then joining them together
like i said using the query planner you
can specify the join keys that you want
to use
and they may be multi-part join keys
even over
the type of join you'd like to do which
is by default an inner join
um but then then you have to basically
decide where to output that
uh you're going to get back at basically
a large data frame
and that data frame you can say i'd like
to have it in pandas or you can say just
please materialize it to a file system
or an object store as this file format
so what a data scientist will do and
this hopefully should save data science
a bit of
work is that well firstly they'll browse
the feature stores for features they'll
and you know they'll look at
distributions of feature values
and get an understanding for them and
then decide to create training data so
this is a data frame
and we have another parameter here which
says pandas equals true
which means you're going to you want to
pan this data frame back if you don't by
default it will be a pi spark data frame
and it will assume that this code is
running
in a spark environment and the other
call if you're just running in a python
environment is
it'll make a rest call in our platform
and
then when you call create training data
set it will run a job on our platform
to do the join for you and to actually
then save
the output data in the file system that
you want to use
so that's what this second call is doing
fs
create training data set it's actually
going to materialize it so we specify
our file format
everything here is version so train data
sets are versioned
uh feature groups of versions and
features individually are versioned
now this is a little um a preview for a
new api we're releasing at the end of
this month
and we've made it a little bit more
complex because i said that
well this assumes a flat name space of
features
well what we've actually done is we've
introduced um
feature groups as a kind of a first
class entity now to make it easier for
users to scope
their features so if for example you
have two features with the same
name so maybe the name of that feature
is id
and but if it belongs to a feature group
so maybe the features group name is
titanic so we have a scope now
titanic slash id and maybe we have then
the bank
account has the as a an id feature
as well so these are two different
features
two different feature groups sorry but
they have the same feature name
so what we do in this case is and this
is a more pythonic api
is that we get back feature groups so we
have two feature groups here
and what we can do is we can basically
say select all of the features from the
titanic feature group and join them with
all of the features from the bank
feature group again it will use
um the query planner to find the largest
overlapping
subset of uh primary key columns between
the two feature groups
so this data frame that you get back you
can again
same as before you can materialize it to
[Music]
in this case materializing is done by
calling td.save so
the training data side is actually in in
the new api it's a it's a map it's just
a metadata object
and you need to call save on it actually
then uh
so it's lazily it's gonna it's not going
to actually
save it save that data frame until you
you call tv.save
so in this case we have an example
showing a connector so how do we use an
s3 bucket well we define a connector for
it or we
we read the connector for it and then we
specify that as the output that's where
we're going to put it
and also in the new api you can
automatically specify the splits in your
in your training and
test and validation data sets so that
would be a random
data
okay i see any no cure q as yet so
i'll keep going okay so here's something
that that is a little bit more
um uh esotheric but if we do support
something about
time travel on feature groups so we have
this abstraction of feature groups
and feature groups can get updated they
get updated every hour if you have an
hourly update or every
30 seconds or minute and for feature
groups that get updated more than every
minute maybe every 10 minutes we can use
this
hoodie storage format so it's
effectively
it's a layer on top of parquet which is
a file format
and it supports atomic updates to these
feature groups it also
supports incremental updates and it also
supports the ability to do what we call
time travel to say
give me the data as it looked at this
point in time so with this commit which
you can
also supply with the timestamp or you
can also say give me the range of data
that arrived between
these two time intervals so in our case
the api looks something like this
i can say for a feature group i can say
i would like the titanic feature group
as it looked like at this moment in time
and i can also say give me the data that
arrived into the bank
feature group the start time and this
end time
and then we can work with these feature
groups as before we can join features
across them and then
materialize them so this is a good
example of this would be for example if
you want to take
training data to be between the years
2012 and 2017
and then your test date is 2018 where
you can just get the data that arrives
in that range for the training and
the other one for the test
so we move on the online feature store
is uh is
how online applications access this
feature store in our case we provide a
jdbc api
so the online applications can start up
and say hey i would like to get back
what we call
a prepared theme which says this is all
the features
that make up the feature vector um that
i'm going to send to the model for
predictions
but i'm missing a lot of the feature
values so that
that query is going to get sent over
jdbc to the
online app to get into our online
database our online feature store
and it will return back the entire
feature vector so the online application
may be missing a bunch of features it
gets them back
and then when it has the future vector
it can send it to the model for
prediction
now this could be done as well inside
the model if you want or can be done in
the application
um and it's pretty flexible framework
in one or the other so in the cloud uh
all of this is hey day ha across
availability zones
both for model serving and for um
feature serving so how this looks in
practice is a little bit more detail
is that our online application here will
have some primary keys so maybe it's
user id
shopping cart id um it might be the
titanic passenger name or something like
that
and uh those keys um are the primary
fees that we're going to use to look up
uh the feature groups effectively so
what you do is when you start up as you
say well here's the name of the model i
trained or here's the name of the
training data set
that i used to train this model with
give me back a prepared statement and
then that prepared statement will be
filled in with the key values that you
supply and from there you'll get back
your
your feature vector and you can send it
then for prediction to the model
i'm going to take a question a little
bit is it possible by more filters than
time while reading the data
yes so when we uh when we create feature
groups you can just apply lambda
expressions as
as a feature um you can call filter on
it
and then have a land expression to
filter out the data you're not
interested in
okay so um the feature store is part of
hopsworks copsex is slightly bigger than
just a feature store you can use it to
train models you can even
plug in kubernetes to serve models and
monitor
and then we support um spark and link
for doing uh batch processing and
there's even kafka
a file system and airflow in there so
it's quite a quite a complete platform
it runs on premise and in uh
in the cloud but i'll just show you how
this fits the feature store fits into an
end-to-end pipeline taking your raw data
this is our raw data here
so our raw data is in our in our data
lake and our data warehouse and our
kafka topics and
what happens is we we looked at feature
engineering to get that data into the
feature store
and at next point you need a data
science platform and what you typically
will do is you'll select a bunch of
features
and then these features you'll often
you'll materialize them but sometimes
you'll just have a pandas data frame and
you'll train directly on that
and if you've materialized them then
you'll have another notebook for example
to train the model
and then you'll need the next step to
validate your model so to do model
analysis uh scoring of your models and
if they're good enough you'll publish
them to a model repository
or model registry so our platform
includes
all of these parts we even have support
for experiments like ml flow
if you have a model registry batch
applications can use them directly
but you also often want to deploy those
models to serving infrastructure
so the key point here is that that
the on feature store will supply
features with low latency either
directly to the model or to the
application
you need to build the future vectors uh
in order to be able to
make your predictions and and things
that are important are things like if
you're using numpy
well how are the features ordered in
that numpy array
so we let the feature store handle that
the platform is a little bit more than
this
and there's things like multi-worker
training asynchronous
hyper-parameter tuning project-based
multi-tenancy
you can read up on it on our website we
have a provenance
and you can try it out so it's free
right now to try at hopsearch's ai it'll
be free for the summer
and there is a community version you can
just install it's completely fully
featured
and the licensing model is hplv3 for
open source
and we do provide an enterprise version
where we we provide a few connectors for
things like um kerberos so active
directory
and github support and kubernetes
integration
i'm not going to follow this demo so um
what i'll just show you is the platform
and just show you a couple of seconds
how to get started
i'll take two minutes so this is
hopsworks.ai
you can just register here and when you
register you can either get a demo
instance that you can just play with and
this is you can connect your aws account
and when you connect your aws account
you can then create a cluster
and you can create it wherever you want
and click your way through to your
cluster but i'm going to skip creating a
cluster i'm just going to show you the
platform directly
so this is an instance running here i'm
not sure what region that's running in
but it's running somewhere
um in the cloud i guess i've already
logged in so i just logged in again
this is the project i was going to show
you it's called churn
you can create many projects here
they're like github repos
um it's in my github if you go to jim
dowling slash turn you'll find the code
for this
but this particular example is a it's a
a telecom
churn data set and i created a feature
group from it and you can see
if we have a quick look at the feature
group you can see there's a lot of
features in here and these are the
distributions of the different feature
values down here
but we also have things like correlation
correlation matrices we compute and this
is quite a big one
we'll take a couple of seconds to show
that this clustering analysis so these
are pre-computed when we
ingested uh into the feature store
and there's distributions of features
you can do data validation
and add storage connectors an overview
with 47 features in that feature group
you're going to do individual features
and then you can even create train data
sets from the ui if you want to
if you want to try it out you can use
jupyter notebooks in here
and what's very interesting is that we
can actually make jupiter notebooks into
jobs
and you can have a bunch of jobs like we
talked about selecting features could be
one notebook
another job could be training a model
another one be val daily model and then
you can even turn that into an
airflow um uh workflow we have a ui
support for just
adding jobs in your notebook jobs
into that workflow so that's a brief
overview of the platform there are
other support for things like
experiments i don't have any here to
show
and model serving and models i don't
have any in here i don't believe
um but you can you can check it out in
your own time and we have plenty
material on our website
so um with that i'll um
i'll uh say thank you to you for
listening and you can find out more on
our github repo um
logical hopsworks uh feel free to fork
it
um contribute we're on twitter and
a lot of people have worked on this
platform and with that i said thank you
and i notice there's a question so i'll
take
uh the first question i think we have a
couple of minutes left for questions
so how is gdpr sensitive managed as in
that separating some way from non-gdpr
data
that's a really good question so firstly
the data inside these projects
is um completely isolated so if i have
many projects
um i can't read data from the other
projects while i'm inside this project
so if i run a notebook or a job in here
i get a new user identity for every
project we're using tls certificates
internally to identify
users and your user identity when you
run a job is
the project name in this case churn and
my username squashed together so if i
have two projects i have two users so if
i want to explicitly share data between
them
i have to actually go to my feature
store and say i'll share this feature
store with another project
you can do that the other thing that we
can do is
which is very nice is in the feature
store we can tag
data we can tag these feature groups so
this feature group here is telecom well
actually adds a tag to it called privacy
level pii
and we can search globally across any
you might have a development a
production feature store
a staging one but we can search for pii
and i can even do partial searching so i
go pi
and it's syncing that to two and then it
finds it right so this so i can
find all my features that are pii this
way
for example i think we have another
question a couple coming up all right
great
um so if my data is on google cloud then
can i still connect to this platform
well you can install the platform on
google cloud
and um it can read from uh so when you
install it on google cloud it'll read
from
um gcps for you so i
think if you go to our read the docs or
hopsworks dot read the docs
uh there's installation instructions for
installing the community version
on getting started i think it's three
lines it's like um
you can you can just create a vm and
just do this
there is actually early support for
spinning up the vms if you
clone a repo called carmel chef we have
a script that will will spin up a vm and
then install it for you but if you just
spin up a vm yourself on google cloud or
gcp you can run this and it will install
the platform there one more question
right all right well that's not why
um okay
i think any more questions
is it possible to store features in
azure for example blob storage
so um we're so we we support spark in
the platform i didn't go into too much
detail so you can run spark jobs
when you install um we're running spark
on top of yarn currently
and in the yarn environment or the
hadoop environment there are loads of
connectors for everything from
you can read in your data from you know
uh s3 or gcs or
as your um data lake or azure blob
storage that's no problem
we haven't moved to kubernetes yet for
spark because basically kubernetes
doesn't work
well enough um shuffling in kubernetes
and spark is
is just not good enough uh we may
eventually move to fully
kubernetes when that problem has been
resolved
um again you can um you can
so they thing is a little bit different
about installing on azure is that you
have to
um you have to add support for private
dns zones and we have some scripts that
will do that for you
um but you azure vms don't come with
private dns which is a bit weird
so you don't for the domain names
because we're using certificates
we need to fill the qualified domain
name so we need that from azure
and could you integrate with ml flow for
example um
if your system is already using mfo for
serving models so mfo does not serve
models
emma flows for managing experiments um
uh i wish i had a a ui and a demo
instance to show
you um you'll have to tune into another
uh episode
um but what we do is we we um we
actually support
something very similar to ammo flow we
had a couple of talks i think about it
recently
um so what the issue with mfl that we
had was that you have to rewrite your
code you you're polluting your code with
all these logging statements
um and you have to put your code inside
a scope
to run it and so what we do is because
everything is going through our file
system
and what we do is for example when you
save a model to our file system
well we know that happens we have a cdc
api to our file system
and then we just store that event that
this particular model was stored in this
particular folder so we know the version
of it and we know the application we see
the application id from from yarn
we know the train data set as well that
was used to train that model so
we're collecting a lot of that and we
call that implicit provenance you can
read up i think we had a
with a paper at a sysml workshop
recently
and um we had a talk i think early late
last year on
mfo is still good i mean
thank you so much yeah thank you so much
for amazing talk
uh those are interesting and i'm very
much looking forward to having a
bit of an easier life and my work as a
data scientist going forward
thank you so much for your work and for
your talk and great to have you here
over here